doubters do you have doubters you know
the people in your life who tell you all
the reasons why you're not gonna make it
why you should quit why should do
something else that you've got a stupid
idea
I call these people the little man
here's the good news you're not alone
Marilyn Monroe was let go from her first
movie contract because the production
chief thought she was unattractive dr.
Seuss's first book was rejected by 27
publishers before was finally picked up
Elvis Presley was fired by the Grand Old
Opry manager who told him you ain't
going nowhere son you ought to go to
driving a truck little man can be an
expert if your aunt bath or your old
high school friends tell you that you
should abandon your dream it hurts but
you can always truck it off and tell
yourself they just don't know what
they're talking about but quite often
the little man is an expert in your
field he knows what he's talking about
he could have years of experience and be
a big player only you can kill your
dream if you have a dream to do
something than the only person who can
get in the way from that happening is
you what if Marilyn Monroe listened to
that production chief what if dr. Seuss
listen to those 27 publishers what if
Elvis Presley listened to the Grand Old
Opry manager he'd be driving truck
dreaming of a life that could have been
it's hard the bigger your dream the more
people are going to tell you that it's
not possible
the more obstacles you're going to have
in your way the more you're going to
doubt yourself it's hard but you have to
keep going
otherwise you'll be driving truck
instead of living out your dream and
that's not because of the little man
that's on you it's your choice I have a
little man in my life when I lost my
belief by video series an expert in the
video production business said it was
too long it would never work fast
forward for months and that first video
has over 400,000 views and is growing
every day now I'm writing a book and top
people in the book industry don't like
my idea
but I'm gonna make it happen it's my
choice not theirs it's my dream not
theirs if you have a dream go out and
make it happen take steps every single
day to do something to move it forward
I don't let anybody hold you back
believe